do people enjoy this let me taste if
it's a shock BP beats know we're
changing diets
[Music]
hey my name is 10 and I'm sawasdee and
this week we're gonna swap diets for a
week
our butts are pretty different they're
similar in the way that we we both are
fitness enthusiasts try and eat kind of
help you're like I'll have Greek yogurt
or I'll have an apple I just eat a bunch
of garbage mad candy bars mad McDonald's
how do you think you'll do I think it'll
be ok ok my wallet won't be the free
food in our canteen is a lot of salt you
work in health care you should know are
you concerned about sodium you sound
really salty about that the only thing
I'm nervous about is the monster I'm
trying to eat a healthier I guess
flavor-wise for certain things were
diverse on that I'm nervous about the
disgusting amounts of egg whites and
grilled chicken I'm gonna have to eat
during this week welcome to my world
baby I think this is going to basically
just prove to me that I like the way I
eat yeah I don't think it's gonna go
well Donny has no work today so he's
visiting me
I spent $9 coffee at Subway okay I
usually watch my budget
[Music]
lunch this is a full meal well we have a
free lunch today so I didn't pay for
lunch all right look like Donny's
picking his poison
it's good for your gut Donny I got you
watermelon and that's a really good
flavor
all right the bunny loves monster and
try it
under Kombucha this is my favorite
flavor this is the one that we have at
work I'm not gonna smell it this is
smells horrible I'm just going to do
this
it's our drink if you don't smell it
it's actually okay it's okay you don't
have to finish it if you don't want to
thank you alright so we just took a walk
over to the Coffee Bean and Tea Leaf I
usually get the winter dream tea latte
so I'm giving that to tend to have today
yeah I usually get the cookie butter a
big fan and a cookie butter latte so day
1 is done and I did find but only
because we had free food at BuzzFeed
today and but tomorrow I'm a little
worried because I'm just gonna be
scavenging I could pack lunch but I
didn't prepare and I'm not really a
great cook so we'll see how tomorrow
goes and if I end up starving then I'll
pack some lunch the next day all right
time to take a sip of this winter dream
tea cookie butter for me you know I'm
still not really [ __ ] with tea like
that this is just underwhelming it's
good but I know that that's better
we're in his way hope I wish they ran me
over so that I didn't have to continue
to treat this with the green tea latte
so I just came back from Panda Express
where normally I would buy lots and lots
of orange chicken
but swass teas go to item there is honey
walnut shrimp so I just got myself a
great deal of honey walnut shrimp I'm
not terribly happy about it but you know
I've actually never tried it oh I think
it's not bad
it's not orange chicken
there's no minds we have college is
really good it's not for you right this
is why we work about this is how why we
make money
I like hmm gotta work for the food all
right so SWA steets an unreasonable
amount of plain Chobani every day to get
her protein in it's a wonderful dairy
product however I prefer when its
flavored I'm not really looking forward
to this I'm not having a good time
I just ate instant ramen and lots and
lots of nuts I just kept eating nuts
while I was working instead I'm
constantly hungry
it's French those I'm so happy so I'm
here at McDonald's gonna order food like
10 my stomach is so high um could I
order a McChicken please with large
fries swathi it's a pretty ridiculous
amount of soup specifically chicken
noodle soup I caught some chicken noodle
soup and now I'm gonna eat it I'm not
really feeling it I don't know how or
why she does this Here I am with the
McDonald's that I ordered earlier you
know all I want is a fruit of vegetables
some oatmeal some soup but I have fries
and a chicken sandwich that I have to
eat my stomach is like unable to process
all of this right now
but so I'm at my favorite coffee place
and I know I'm not supposed to spend for
coffee but my boss was craving coffee
and she told me if I come down here and
buy her one she'll get me one for free
so not cheating in an effort to eat and
drink like 10 I guess I have to go
I think I've actually ever tried it in
my life let's see how this is you know
what try to get behind this and I want
like a complete diet so this is fiber
hummus is protein I don't need that much
calcium Shibani with mixed berries for
dessert it's the complete healthy life
all right
eating like ten here's a plate that's
eight ounces of chicken disgusting this
is because I ate snacks all day it's 11
p.m. I'm a little bit hungry but not as
hungry as I was when I just had instant
ramen for lunch also an update I am
saving a lot of money today's actually a
really busy day for me I have
back-to-back meetings so I have 15
minutes to stuff this cereal down my
throat like this is the quickest lunch
that I could get and I could find I
really have no time to be picking some
if 10 was here he would definitely go
for these chips because that's all he
eats all day long
eating likes Wasti is kind of difficult
I would say because it's not necessarily
like the kind of foods that I enjoy I
mean it's not the worst thing in the
world but it's um it's not the best I
miss my own diet a lot actually I'm
saving money because even though fast
food is incredibly cheap grilled chicken
and stuff is is more expensive trying
not to be too TMI right now but after
eating like 10 for about half a week my
stomach is just oh it's really bubbly in
there you guys I had a long day today
I'm craving pasta so I'm here at this
Filipino place called jolly beet and
they have spaghetti that's under five
dollars because I am a good white I am
gonna get my husband what I usually get
which is a lot of food
ten drinks probably the one to two
liters of Diet Mountain Dew every day I
don't know how he does it I'm about
halfway through and I feel really gassy
and uncomfortable but I committed to it
so so this is actually what I usually do
have no problem eating this even though
stressful orders this because I love
palabra intricate work who doesn't the
only reason they don't order it this
it's expensive it's not expensive it's
just like seven dollars or something
it's more expensive than that well yeah
you don't finish your food so eat your
leftover so it's okay so tomorrow we're
gonna go to our pan Express but it's not
your regular pan Express it's not
actually the Panda Express here at
Monterey Park which is 90 presentation
so it's a special Panda Express hi not
all the same for dinner today I'm eating
this footlong Subway sandwich but I like
it more than what he usually eats
because there's vegetables in it
so I like this this is good
all right so for the last day of the
challenge we're going to Panda Express
Donny's favorite so unlike your regular
Panda Express this Ashley has healthy
stuff like quinoa kale all those fancy
stuff plus it has Panda Express burrito
so what are you having quinoa and orange
chicken yeah best right best ever
that's my go-to food in Panda Express
[Music]
Beijing beef quinoa and brown rice and
charmin just collect so much food ah I
feel bad making it go to waste so I'm
gonna eat all her leftovers so eating
like ten has been super difficult every
so often I'll go to the canteen and I
will go grab like a Chobani and I'm like
wait I can't eat that this week I really
miss my own diet my stomach is not happy
I can't eat the amount that I eat
it's just like too much on my digestive
system it's been a week how was your
experience funny it was good sense a
proper eating healthy and not eating
fasted for a week I definitely noticed a
big difference in my wallet this is
exactly how I expected this to go I
don't mind eating healthy I just need to
find a place probably where I can eat
healthy and not spend like fifteen
twenty dollars per meal why don't you
pack your lunch and not look I will not
change up my eating habits maybe I'll
like have a couple of those chips with
chips Pocky chips ah that's a pocket
yeah good what I did learn though is
that its digestive system I guess is a
lot better than mine you know she's not
built for that fast food life
I need a food I think is one of the joys
of life is ID if you earn enough money
you should be able to treat yourself
oh yeah that's that yeah it's a wrap go
back to our regular ways of eating
thank you
you